die lustigsten Schülerantworten im Test
ist mit 8,6 Millionen aufrufen mit das
meistgeklickte Video auf meinem
YouTube-Kanal von daher habe
ich habe mir auf jeden Fall gedacht dass
ich das heute noch mal hochladen
die erste Frage einer Klassenarbeit die
in der dritten Klasse gestellt wurde
lautet was ist eine Legende der Schüler
hat geantwortet Ronaldo bei der nächsten
lustigen Antwort sollte der Schüler das
erste Wort aufschreiben dass ihm bei
folgenden Begriffen eingefallen ist bei
Deutschland hat er dann z.B Berlin
geschrieben bei Rathaus hat der
Bürgermeister geschrieben und bei Schule
hat er Hölle geschrieben
[Musik]
es klatscht tatsächlich niemand Luca
nenne den Begleiter folgender Begriffe
und Begleiter ist glaube ich in der
Grundschule noch so das Wort wird
Artikel also der die das deswegen sollte
man hier scharf und und Frau mit das
Schaf der Hund und die Frau beantworten
er hat allerdings schäferchen und Mann
geschrieben weil er sich dachte ein
Schaf brauchen Schäfer ein Hund brauchen
Herrchen und und eine Frau brauchen Mann
alles klar Bro finde das Gegenteil krank
logischerweise gesund bei hell ist das
Gegenteil auch logischerweise dunkel und
bei pünktlich logischerweise unglücklich
denkt man er dachte allerdings pünktlich
ist auf Punkte bezogen hat deswegen
kariert geschrieben
du fliegst direkt von der Schule was
wurde im Referat von Cornelius als
einfachste Methode herausgearbeitet um
eine neue Sprache Lokal betrachtet am
ehesten sprechen und verstehen zu können
Sprachen lernen Babbel Sprachen lernen
Babbel bei der nächsten lustigen Antwort
sollte man entweder kleiner oder größer
Schreiben der Schüler hat allerdings die
ganze Zeit nur oder geschrieben
eigentlich sollte man ja die Zahlen
bewerten welche Größe und welche kleiner
ist er dachte sich allerdings dass das
oder ja nicht ohne Grund da
reingeklammert ist oder dachte er soll
deswegen oder schreiben dass du dumm
bist berechne die in Abbildung drei
gezeigte Formel und kürzer das habe ich
getan und ich glaube dass sie da
ebenfalls drauf kommen können alles klar
einfach mal die Aufgabe zurücknehmen
Lehrer geben nenne drei deutsche Städte
beginnen mit dem Buchstaben k
Assel
Koblenz Karstadt
[Musik]
wo wurde der Nordatlantik Vertrag
unterzeichnet und warum unten und darum
ob die ersten Menschen waren und
normalerweise wird mir jetzt
überschreiben wie Höhlenmenschen oder
Neandertaler davon das noch sagen
hört sich so an als ob da auch irgendwas
drin wäre was man Politiker Crack nicht
mehr sagen dürfte als du neandert bist
entschuldigung ich wollte jetzt nicht
persönlich attackieren der Schüler hat
hier allerdings nicht so etwas in die
Richtung der Beschreibung dieser
Menschen damals geschrieben sondern
einsam
die ersten Menschen waren einsam und ich
bin ganz ehrlich er hat recht wir hatten
ja auch noch kein instagram
um sich zu connecten ich habe Instagram
vorbei schauen hier lautet die Aufgabe
30 plus 40 Bro woher kommt diese
Klassenarbeit dick aus dem Kindergarten
auf jeden Fall Leute die
Aufgabenstellung wie rechnest du hier
schreibe auch auf der Schüler antwortet
mit den Fingern auf ich frag jetzt
vielleicht warum schreibt er da auf hin
hier steht halt schreibe auf
und er dachte dass er dann auf
schreiben
Kinder sind süß aber auch extrem blöd
welche Geschenke
brachten die drei Weisen dem Jesuskind
mit
gold
Weihrauch
Karotten
ich
ja was bemisst die
Richterskala Erdbeeren
Erdbeben
Bro nicht nicht Erdbeeren wie erklärst
du dir warum Gustav die mit
d35.000 Gramm die falsche Antwort wird
der ist sogar in der Fragestellung
einfach schon Fehler ist aber an sich
vom Lehrer psychologisch gesehen eine
ganz coole Frage weil du als Schüler
dann beantworten musst wie man eventuell
auf die falsche Lösung hätte kommen
können um das in Zukunft nicht zu
wiederholen oh das war richtiges Deutsch
danke danke der Schüler beantwortet die
Frage allerdings mit weil Gustav schon
immer dumm war alles klar Bruder Gustav
setz dich mal lieber in den Bus ab
[Applaus]
wie werden aus Zentimeter Meter
wenn man das Zenti wegstreicht
ist halt
ist halt auch richtig
Delfine Meeresfrüchte Bananen Äpfel etc
was halt so gerade ins Meer geworfen
wurde alles klar dicker
Meeresfrüchte sind laut ihm einfach
Früchte die vom Strand
ins Meer geworfen wurde Tobi bei der
nächsten Aufgabe handelt es sich um
einen Sport Theorietest ich hatte das
ehrlich gesagt nie wir hatten noch keine
Sport elkas oder so angeboten bei uns in
der Schule weil die dann glaube ich von
allen hätten belegt werden würden
geschrieben Reisepass Skipass und passiv
so das ist so völlig banal eine
Reisepass ist ein wirklich richtiges
deutsches Dokument zum Reisen skip
das ist keine Ahnung es hat auf jeden
Fall alles nichts mit Sport zu tun wozu
dienen die Stäbchen der Netzhaut es tut
mir wirklich leid aber ich habe null
Plan na ja
nichts na ja bis halt einfach blöd jeder
weiß doch wozu die Stäbchen in der
Netzhaut dienen
ist
wirklich nicht
helfen Bruder erklär doch nicht ich muss
aufnehmen
einfach selbst miteinander unterhalten
ehrlich gesagt
ja beschreibe die Vermehrung des
Frosches bumsen
so dumm heute beschreibe was der Elefant
auf dem Bild tut und wahrscheinlich war
das irgendwie ein biologietest 7 Klasse
der Elefant hat gerade irgendwie seinen
Haut mit dem Rüssel geheult ja irgendwie
keine Ahnung ich habe das Bild nicht
gesehen irgendwas hat er wahrscheinlich
gemacht
Schüler schreibt einfach berührten
nenne drei zusammengesetzte namenwörter
Schulbus Deutschbuch und Globus er meint
aber glaube ich den Globus
globusse sind auch richtig nice
irgendwie ne fand ich Friedrich krass
ich wollte immer ein Globus
Schüler
[Musik]
Amt
ja ich muss das auch nicht so episch
machen ist ein ganz normales Youtube
Video in der sechs Tiere die in der
Antarktis leben und er sagt einfach zwei
Eisbären sechs Seehunde das zusammen
sind auch nicht mal sechs das sind acht
er sollte halt sechs verschiedene Tiere
er sagt zwar dann sagt doch wenig
ihr seid alle so blöd
mein Handy an perfekt wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann